[Music]
famed food critic chef author and TV
personality Anthony Bourdain has died of
an apparent suicide at the age of 61
Bourdain was in France working on his
CNN series parts unknown when he was
found by his close friend and french
chef eric repair in his hotel room on
Friday morning
CNN confirmed the news in a statement
writing his love of great adventure new
friends find food and drink and the
remarkable stories of the world made him
a unique storyteller his talents never
cease to amaze us and we will miss him
very much
shortly after the tragic news broke
stars took to social media to express
their grief Chrissy Teigen tweeted quote
Anthony one of my idols unapologetic
passionate and one of the best
storytellers on the planet thank you for
making food so exciting and always
standing up for everything right
horrible
why why why be at peace now while Gordon
Ramsay wrote stunned and saddened by the
loss of Anthony Bourdain he brought the
world into our homes and inspired so
many people to explore cultures and
cities through their food Bourdain is
survived by his 11 year old daughter and
his girlfriend Asia Argento
[Music]